hello and welcome everybody to Udacity
robotics QA I'm Mike Salem and I'm here
with CEO and co-founder of kiwi felipe
chavez Felipe how are very good and
thank you very much for inviting me I'm
very excited to be here degree we're
glad to have you in studio today thank
you very much for stopping by as what if
you could tell me a little bit about
Kiwi robotics and exactly what you guys
are working on okay so with Kiwi we are
building robots for food delivery so
basically our goal is to build out the
first or run infrastructure rubble urban
infrastructure that allows us to deliver
and good robot yeah cool so where are
you using these robots were you
deploying your robots right now so we
think that in in order to deploy faster
and to write the word product better we
need the perfect spot to do it is
college campuses so that's why we
started UC Berkeley and right now like
next semester we're going to start in a
second campus yeah okay great so it
sounds like is you have a mobile robot
base yes you take and you kind of deploy
around campus and it drops off food for
hungry hungry college students yes one
of the things that we realized is that
actually delivery is very expensive yes
so when you try to order a burrito an
angular burrito you ain't paying $5 for
the delivery fee $3 for the service fee
and also you have to tape so it's - I'm
bearing both with the student community
and like we students are broke so we
don't have like enough mana to to you to
pay luxury so we basically start to
rethink how delivery works and we
started to see that it's not truly
optimized because like for example if
you order from an on-demand app and it's
just one person going to a restaurant
and then go to the customer house but
with rubbish we can actually start to
group robots and optimize a lot of
things so that's really fun so with your
robots can you actually do custom orders
so you can you go to you know multiple
restaurants do multiple orders from
smaller let's say mom-and-pop type of
shops so so one of the things that we
have learned is that in order to deploy
robots to real life and we still need
human
so for example in UC Berkeley we still
have a people in the restaurant zone
that is in charge for example if we
don't have a partnership with the
restaurant or the restaurant doesn't
have our app to receive our orders and
we just have a person that it's going
into the restaurant and buys the food
and pick the food up and the robot is in
front of the restaurant waiting for the
order right so we still need a we are
still need humans to empower this this
infrastructure yeah cool so you can tell
me a little bit about the size your
robot and maybe some of the sensors that
you have on board yes so and we studied
like our first approach was to basically
build the network server so we can
actually control the robots right so to
do that we we started with a basic with
basic parts so we used an Arduino or
Raspberry Pi and and I am you and also
one of the things that we have suffered
a lot but we already solved is internet
connection so we have to ensure that we
have very good LTE at any time so that's
why our robots are like used on a
smartphone yes so that the other
computer that we have in into India in
robot we in the first version and we use
like lasers laser sensors and also
transonic sensors but as soon as really
started to work more with computer
vision and we started to try to replace
those sensors with colors that's really
interesting because a lot of people seem
to be going the other way
right the yes either start off with like
I need a lidar and I need you know 15 or
20 ultrasonic sensors because I'm
worried about running into things you've
taken more of a computer vision approach
and kind of really cut back on the
amount of sensors you need and trying to
run pretty much everything right off of
your camera yes I think that in order to
solve automation or self-driving you
need to solve vision you can't do a
self-driving rabbit or a self-driving
car without solve vision so that's
fundamental and that's why we are
investing so heavily in that
and basically what we are trying to do
is to for example and we try in our our
main problem is to ensure that the robot
is inside the sidewalk yes and it's
actually pretty challenging like for me
in my perspective it's easier to ensure
that the robot is in the like that the
car is in the road between the lines
sure but with a rabbit in our side work
like the every side work is different we
don't have the lines to to make the line
detection so we have for example we have
a lateral we're using lateral cameras to
recognize and buildings to recognize
trees to trying to identify the curbs
so all those things like we we're using
a camera as a sensor and we are using
like like like the same approach of
sensor fusion but just with cameras and
GPS yeah interesting so how many cameras
do you actually have onboard your robot
at six cameras six cameras yes and
you're able to kind of pull all that
information together to make a decision
is that how that typically works yes so
so right now what is interesting is that
not any sensor is totally reliable yes
not even not even GPS well there are
some GPS sensor that that's super
reliable that are really expensive yes
and when you are actually building not
robots for research but also robots for
delivering you need to make sure that
the robot is going to pay by itself in
in in the future so that's why we are we
are using that like these approaches
yeah so how big are your robots
approximately so the new model is 25
centimeters and
well we have the chances that it's 12
centimeters okay it I think you need to
measure in inches millimetres is okay
right so that's roughly about half but
it's about six inches high roughly a
little bit less than that everybody out
there but exactly one of the things that
we are identified is that our first
version was a little bit bigger yes but
we are working in sidewalks so sidewalks
are like a really sacred thing for
people so that's why our robots we are
trying to build robots that are that are
not going to and only going to bother
people that's why it's size like having
a small size matters and we have to
optimize everything inside the robot to
have enough has paid space to transfer
to meals so we Robert said that they've
like the payload capacity it's five
pounds and we can actually like we want
to just transport two meals yeah okay so
it's meant for a two-person delivery
it's just typically a good size usually
it's you and a friend maybe it's two
separate people two different locations
so it's a little bit more of an
optimization a logistics problem but it
still meant for really kind of light
easy travel yeah Satya actually I wear
weak point it's pizza yeah we can
transport pizza but we think that like
I'm like according to our like like
they're the orders that we have received
and we can cover with our current model
94 95 percent of the orders so yeah sure
and there's there's already Pizza
Delivery robots out there Domino's has
their pizza delivery robot right yeah
but they don't what they don't have is a
mom-and-pop yeah Restaurant delivery
robot right so you have a leg up on
Domino's already yeah but the thing
about like when the first and and I
think that this could be interesting so
my background is in delivery space so I
have been working in the delivery spends
the last four years of course I have
been an enthusiast in robotics and also
in AI for several years but I always
thought that that will be super
difficult like you just do you need like
millions of dollars and you need
scientific like like do you need
scientists like a lot of sort of things
so the first approach was well there are
companies like like dominoes that
they're building their own robots maybe
it's it could be a good idea to buy
those robots
yes I'm sure to try to run them sure and
the thing that we actually encountered
is that there are a lot of a robotic
companies that are making research yes
so they're building just one rabbit at a
time and making sure that it's 100%
autonomous and using expensive velobind
and lighter sensors and things like that
so that's why we decided to build our
own robots and until now we have
delivered and since our launch to week
10 weeks ago we have delivered
2,000 orders with our robots the last
week of classes we delivered five
hundred orders and we were the company
in the world that made more deliveries
on demand
yeah with robots wow that's fantastic
congratulations thank you very much so I
know you mentioned a little little
earlier that your background is in more
of delivery so it sounds like I believe
your background is related more to
business side of things and that's so
much the technical side of things what
are some of the struggles that you've
kind of encountered when you were
starting your company that you felt like
you had to overcome not being from the
technical background there is a good
thing that I want to tell and is that
most people when you are hiring try to
underestimate the to overestimate
experience so when people are hiring are
trying to look like what you have done
what is your experience what is your
background but for example right now in
my team I have have bring some people
that are new in the area that maybe
don't have some experience ask me and
what I have encountered is that when you
have someone that doesn't have too many
like like does it have too much
experience they don't know what is
impossible yes so when people don't know
what is impossible they can actually
achieve very interesting things so I
remember that the first time I asked
someone with like a lot of like with
very strong background about having
using noodle networks or computer vision
to your object detection he told me that
I was crazy and that they will that will
take like a pair of like a couple of
years and but we did it in a couple of
months so that are the kind of things
that when you don't have experience
maybe that could be a good thing and
this space is totally new like we are
totally new in this space
so and yeah so what you're doing is
you're really kind of curbing your
expectations instead of kind of lowering
your expectations immediately because
you feel like well I have enough
technical background in that area that I
know this is going to be a complicated
or a hard problem because you don't have
any of that background you necessarily
say I just want to go and do this you
try it and you see how long it actually
is going to take and you think that's
big more beneficial for you and your
company in the way that it's operated so
far I think that's for example like I'm
not an engineer and but it's really
important that you actually and like a
understand the fundamentals so I
remember that when I was in college and
like I thought like like algebra that
linear algebra and calculus that's not
I'm not going to use that any like at
any time in my lifetime but actually I'm
now using it yes because now to
understand the fundamentals of machine
learning I remember that we had a
problem with that PWM thing with the
sensor that we were W M is pulse width
modulation yes okay I think that we had
a problem with the Arduino so I actually
had to recover my my small knowledge in
integral like calculus so those kind of
things actually like if you actually
just know the fundamentals it's okay but
if you are going to start a robotic
company and you are not you don't have
technical background you must be like
it's a it's very good to you it's it's
it's mandatory that you actually learn a
little bit like you know how it works I
think that's great advice how important
do you feel it is defined and build how
difficult was it to actually build a
technical team to kind of help you
execute well like how how right now we
are 14 people in the team wow it's a big
team yeah and twelve of them are
engineers so it just me just the
designer and me are the ones that are
not engineers and I think that's a very
good thing that that I'm using right now
to hire people is I try to I get to
first have a conversation as friends and
if I start to have the feeling like
before before the technical part before
if it's very good at the technical part
I try I try to hire people that I will
not have any problem if that person is
my boss yes so yeah that actually have
worked very good with Mia like hiring
people and it's the number one technique
that I use in order to you know we like
which we we'd like to know and how I'm
going to build my team yeah sure so
having a culture fit is such an
important piece of your team because you
feel like you're a very tight-knit team
yes I think that this is a very complex
problem yes we are talking a very
complex problem so there for example
last week was very bad like there we
have a team that is working in image
recognition so they are managing a lot
of libraries happens to be a lot of
things and we didn't have any results so
there are very stressful situations so
if you actually build a team that you
feel comfortable working with them and
that's that's the most important thing
so I think that we are going to solve
and to tackle all the obstacles that
we're going to face it's because we have
a culture and that's super important I
think I think it's a great attitude
actually used to work for for some folks
that one of the things they mentioned to
me is they said you always hire people
smarter than you because if you hire
people that are smarter than you you
know they'll be able to accomplish
everything that you can do and more so
it's a great attitude and great
philosophy to have so I noticed you said
that you have 14 people on your team yes
and there's only two people on your team
who are non-technical and that's you and
another designer how instrumental do you
feel your designer is to your team how
everything has been built so far so a
thing that a design it's pretty
important when you are building robots
robots so and there is a the Baxter yeah
the dead robot I remember that I read
some Sam and I read about them and it
totally changes when you put a face into
the robot yeah sure so they because the
the robot has a face so they solve a lot
of problems just putting a face so for
example Bob robot because we are
interacting with people it totally
changed everything when we put a face
and into the robot so right now we are
trying to build a robot that looks more
like a pet
yes so the Pico people actually can
protect it can take care of it that can
actually forgive an error or thing like
that then building a super high tech
like actually we're building a super
high-tech robot but we prefer to and to
build robots that seems very more like
like a pet so design it's really
important it's a because it's mainly
human perception right so if a human
perceives a robot in a certain way they
tend to behave around it in a certain
way yeah so if a robot looks very
high-tech and complicated they might be
a little bit more standoffish and more
like I don't want to be around that
thing but if it looks more like a pet
you feel like oh I can interact and I
can engage and I can walk and I don't
really have to worry about what this
thing's going to exactly exactly so
there's some interesting other aspects
to your design as well and one of them
is your speed of your robot yeah so how
fast is your robot typically goes so
right now we can go up to 6 miles per
hour but that's not I think that that's
not a very good speed inside works
because right now we reach average is it
3 miles per hour so we try to do it
lower than the human you know speak like
your human walking speed and just for
safety reasons yes so that makes people
feel comfortable around the robot yeah
exactly exactly
yes so let's shift a little bit talk a
little bit more about your CEO duties
and kind of talk about what's your
day-to-day what are the types of things
that you typically focus on as a CEO so
yeah well maybe this is not this is not
too much involved with robotics but and
my main like the main thing is to
actually there's a good management skill
or technique today that I use is that
for example when you're tackling robotic
and engineer problems it's always a
version of that problem that you can
solve in three or four days right so
right now we are trying and that's why
we ended up working with the sensor
fusion thing it's because for example if
I tell my engineer team like hey build
an autonomous robot in the side work and
that doesn't need any human interaction
they're going to tell me like that's
very challenging like we are going to
need a lot of time but but if you just
tell them like hey
I just need a rabbit that goes from one
corner to another corner and straight it
doesn't matter if it's it has collision
avoidance that just that a small problem
or just recognize the traffic lies so
and it's very important one of the jobs
of the CEO is first of all and make sure
that everyone is aligned in what we need
to solve so our first priority for the
next semester the next stage is make it
make 1,000 orders per day that's the
challenge and we want to do it in a 2
miles radius coverage area so that's
going to be actually the first rabbit
infrastructure in the history so if you
have that per like people actually start
to build not a computer vision for the
sake of computer vision of AI but more
most like thinking how we can achieve
like the 1,000 orders maybe because we
still need like our roads are not
totally autonomous we still need a
person that it's making surveillance
that is helping the robot to make the
crossing the streets so yet so that's
one important thing so it sounds like
you're doing a lot of strategic planning
so you're actually giving your team
instead of small term goals well short
burst goals
yeah with a long term horizon as to what
you want to achieve so by saying
basically I want you to take the robot
and go from one corner of the street of
the sidewalk to the next corner of the
sidewalk that's all I care about let's
do that then you at least have a base
and you have a benchmark and you have a
baseline to do things with and then from
there you could say ok now that we've
done that now we want to make sure it
doesn't run into any people right yeah
and then you slowly build on it so
you're giving this order to the rest of
your team but you're giving it to them
in doses that they can handle so they
don't have to worry about all of the
other things that could go wrong whereas
you have the opportunity and the ability
now to sit back and think about those
while still allowing them to focus on
the task at hand to help them progress
and move forward exactly yeah so it's
better like like these spaces talking
about computation and elective learning
and also some some sensors it's so new
and you have a lot of things that to
discover that it's easier and I actually
advise to tackle and a small problems
not tackled but no don't try to tackle
like self-driving totally self-driving
try to recognize what
is more problems you can solve yeah
great so talking about a little bit
about kind of when you start it out with
your company
you had your vision obviously you want
to do something in the delivery space
you had some background there and you
had an idea and you knew robots would
work out really well
talk to me a little bit about your
process of how you went about putting
things together they kind of go and
present and talk to companies to try to
achieve funding yes so the first thing
is to like like I remember when we
started in Berkeley we started with
round robots and first the most
important thing is to actually have
people that want to use your service yes
so we actually had a lot of demand but
yeah we were just with dropping we
didn't have any funding so like we
didn't have enough money to pay like
delivery and couriers do you actually
make the lure like that to make the
deliveries so we were in a situation I
remember that there was one week that
like most of my job a CEO was actually
making deliveries yes and I started
thinking like how I can solve this and
of course I my solution was so extreme
so because I remember that the first
time we were like that we started with a
side project so the there is this
company called plumb geek I don't know
have you heard about now I have not so a
plant week make field educational robots
so and our first side project was to
have an educational robot so that was a
small book and we basically installed an
AI and software in that book and we
basically made our first object and like
collision avoidance and things like that
but that was a side project but what we
identified with that side project is
that this is achievable that the
technology is actually improving a lot
of things and everything like everything
like the planets got aligned so like a
the things with the the the robe that we
have were actually doing very well and
we had a lot of deliveries and we don't
we didn't have enough time to to to make
the deliveries and also don't have any
money to pay couriers and to train
couriers and hire couriers so we decided
to make the first prototype and we build
it in one week and a half
so with that prototype and I remember
that we made half of a delivery because
we had some problems with the battery
and sensors but then I thought that this
is possible and I fully committed so I
stopped I tell all my customers like hey
I'm going to stop one month and please
wait me one month I heard I had three
new people like that are involved in
robotics and we build our first version
that was 10 weeks ago what was your
customers reaction when you came to them
obviously you had a base already of
people that were interested in we're
giving your service you're giving them
deliveries I know you were making
deliveries personally what was the
reaction once you've pulled back and
told them I'm gonna take a week a month
off and I'm gonna go work on something
and I'm gonna come back and do this
again did you have any problems with
your customer base when you did
something like I spoke with some
customers and they told me like they
thought that I will close the company
yeah the four that was the first
reaction but then one week before we
started again I send them an email with
a picture of the robot and the first
reaction was that we receive we received
that day like 20 just just that that in
that night we received like 25
internship requirements so all the all
the students all our customers want to
be internships interns in our in our in
our company so that was very great
yeah I felt very happy like people start
to see oh now these make sense yes so
what I think is kind of interesting
about your company and I had a
conversation around this earlier this
week is that robots aren't the focal
point of your company the focal point of
your company is actually food delivery
and right because building a robot is
great it's nice tag like people like to
play around with tech but you're not
really solving the problem right when
you just built the robot is what I'm
saying so but you've built a robot with
the sole purpose in mind how important
do you think that is for other people to
kind of follow and that that model and
that vision of you know the robot is the
tool
it's not it's not the end goal and I
think that it's like like for like all
right
last week an investor asked me like you
are a delivery company or you're a
rabbit company so and it's like I don't
know it's like it's like asking I'm
asking like 2028 like in the 90s like
you're a book company or you're like an
Internet company so I think that robots
in the livery space and logistic space
are going to be mandatory so you have to
work on that and what we have found that
we didn't have and we didn't find and
found any solution available very good
solution available so we decided to
build our robots like we lower self the
robots yes so it and it's like it's
interesting because for example when I
hired people a lot of people have worked
in robots but just in the research part
like just for like we build it and but
we didn't I don't sell it or put like
veal 100 right now we are in others
we're going to have 100 robots and so
actually wheeling robots marina in a
consumerist scale it's it's fun and it
you have different approaches and
different challenges yeah so can you
elaborate a little bit on some of those
challenges that you have once you start
having robots that scale some of the
things that you kind of see coming up on
your horizon
yeah it's it's like the same when you
are working with just one person if
you're working with just one person is
totally different when you are working
with dozens of people right is the same
with robots so if you make rub it work
just one robot it's okay it's good now
it's a total different challenge I
remember that one of the when we make
the first goal of building one one robot
the next challenge was to have ten
robots working at the same time yes and
that was pretty hard yeah we already
build one but actually to to have ten
we're signed and worked at the same time
it's really difficult and in logistics
are the same so I think that what
actually differentiate us is that we
actually have put proof that we can have
several like dozens of robots working at
the same time and by the next has
semester hundreds of robots working on
the set down and it's a total different
story
yeah so I know you have a couple of
fail-safes to that you have to have when
you're working with your robots so
there's certain situations where you
have to be very careful because you are
interacting with people and you're
around people so one of those is I'm
assuming is around children let's say so
what kind of methods do you have in
place to kind of handle when your robot
is around a child and right now we are
trying to use computer vision to
identify when you when we have a person
that it's really close to the due to the
robot and also to identify the size of
that person so but for example we always
have a human we have a operational team
in Colombia we always have a human we
always have a human that it's watching
the robot remotely yeah so every time
that a key to start to play with robot
every time that we are passing to like
through a very crowded sidewalk and
everything like the last 30 seconds or
thirty second one minute of every
delivery we do it with a human to ensure
that we delivery is successful we do it
with a human so yeah by now we are using
in those extreme situations humans to
take control and make the right decision
yes that's great and I think that's a
really important piece that you have a
human in the loop to kind of handle
those complex situations a lot of times
you'll see people will just rely on
their algorithms and what ends up
happening is there's their ins being
there or something unpredictable has
occurred and it causes all kinds of
different problems so you get some
negative press over things like that but
having a human in the loop kind of
alleviates a lot of those problems yeah
and I think that just in the technical
part of to that the challenge to do that
is actually a network challenge so I
think right now 20 between 20 and 20
percent of all our code is related with
network so we need to ensure that we
have latency and below 150 milliseconds
to take control the robot at any time
that we can actually learn life's like a
stream video in a very good quality bit
with very low latency and also that we
actually don't
too much money in data plans so those
kind of challenges are very interesting
but I'm very optimistic that that the
future is going to allow companies to to
build robots and we can actually we will
be able to connect to those robots and
very easily interesting great so I know
you mentioned you have an operational
team that's in Colombia yes is that
originally where your company came from
when you started this I'm from Colombia
okay we started the company here in the
US and our headquarters are here our
customers are here we build the robots
here in the US our investors are here
and but M for example some like half of
the team is from Colombia and the
operation what came is in Colombia so
yeah okay great and I don't know if you
can speak on this too much but how is
the robotics scene in let's say South
South America is there anywhere in
particular that you know of that there's
a lot of robotic activity I'm very I'm
very sad about that but because you know
I just
and we just read read a review of all
the startups that are working and with
robotics and English in America and
until I know we are the only startup
that came from Latin America that are
work that are that hire our
venture-backed and that are working with
robots yes that have raised more than
$100,000 and so that means that there
are not a lot of people working robotics
in Latin America so one of their of the
reason one of the challenges that we
want to do with Kiwi is to actually and
inspire people that you don't need a lot
of resources because the first tool that
you have when you are building and
creating robots is this is going to cost
a lot of a lot of money and you visit
this is something that it's magic
it's like black magic you can't do it so
one of the things that we want to do and
I we want to make sure is that empower
and inspire more people in other parts
of the world and to start working
robotics and also here in the US I
thought I told you that and there the
CEO the Bela dines CEO and said that
there there is a trend there is a maybe
a hot market but there are not too many
and startups working with robotics yet
so we need more people working in this
place yes so I want to kind of touch
back a little bit on South South America
as well what do you feel would be
beneficial for some of the folks down
there to try to try to get going I know
things the socio-economic stand you know
situations down there a little bit
different than they are here in the
United States what type of things can
they do to try to you know either start
their own companies and kind of trying
to get ventured back in South America or
to kind of you know look for jobs should
they pursue jobs elsewhere what are some
of your recommendations and of course
one of the recommendations is to take a
take a course in Udacity that will be a
super it's a very good sort and one of
the things that we have done is that
because we have some people in Columbia
is to build a synthetic environment so
what that means is that right now we are
building a 3d environment yes and photo
a little bit photorealistic
so that actually people can start to
work with simulated sensors simulated
computer power and simulated robots and
train their software their algorithms
their CNN their neural networks all the
things so I think that that could be a
good start to actually be able to test a
lot of things because well one things
that we have encountered with our robots
is that almost twenty or thirty percent
of the data set that you gather with
real robots are are not in a very good
condition a wrong data set so we are
also very very heavy in field an entire
city with sidewalks and with humans and
with cars that people will be will have
access to train their own robots that's
fantastic and you're planning on an open
source in this data set of this
information the sensor data yeah yes
yeah we are we are still too early yes
and we we are also working with with us
beyond that part and we are going to do
have some amount announcements on that
and but totally my fundamental a willing
is to have more people working on
robotics that I will be super happy that
that
be an achievement for me yeah are you
familiar do know who Yogi Bear is yes
have you ever heard the same is one of
my favorite sayings ever in theory
practice and theory are the same in
practice they're different yeah right so
it's exactly what it is when you deal
with hardware right you have all this
noise nothing ends up working correctly
so giving people the opportunity who
might not be able to afford those
sensors like for instance that you know
not everybody can afford to buy no Bella
dine sent that lidar right hey you give
you the opportunity to at least see some
sort of real data and from a real
environment and allowing them to play
around with that actually is huge for
lots of people lots of folks all over
the world so I think you're doing some
really cool and interesting work so
thank you for that yeah
that's it's still too early but we're we
have very good progress on that
yeah that's great so shifting gears a
little bit more back to your idea of
some of the sensors that are on board I
know you would mentioned earlier that
you have you know six cameras you have
an IMU you have a GPS how do you see
once you start scaling like you said for
the thousand robots there's going to be
some logistical planning kind of in
place for that so what do you see or
some of the new and emerging fields and
robotics that you think might help you
kind of tackle those areas one of the
things that I think there are not enough
companies working is manufacturing
robots yes when you build a robot and
it's and it's because you're not sexy
like you like a lot of people see
manufacture like something like a like I
don't want to work on that but it's
actually pretty fun and I think that
it's very important so if you have a
billet and if you want to build the
robot that builds the robot that's like
like an order of magnitude more complex
yes so I think that a in order to to
have this new revolution of robots and
machines like improving the world we
will need more companies really like
like working in manufacturing that's
that's the thing that I will I'm eager
to have more like more company
and that's something that most people
don't realize right so you typically
your small shop you start off you make
one robot you're like I got a prototype
this is great now I need I got order for
five okay well I can make five and then
you say oh I got an order for fifty I
can make fifty hundred a thousand well
now all of a sudden right you're hitting
this cusp this is breaking point okay
ten thousand okay I definitely can't
make ten thousand out of my garage right
and I think this is one of the biggest
problems that people are kind of facing
right now so I 100% agree with you yes
and I'm actually in a work process of
building our roads we still need a lot
of humans yes like like there are a lot
of manual part manual and procedures
that I'm pretty confident that there
should be a way to to be to build a
robot to build a robot yeah I agree
and that's super exciting like like if I
have if I have to start the company
later it will be in that Philip I'm
pretty excited about that
awesome so are you familiar at all with
swarm robots and swarm theory and no
okay
so the idea idea is basically that if
you have these small entities so for
instance Birds is a good example so we
have birds that are flying they end up
flocking together and end up looking
bigger than they are
actually to help you know avoid being
attacked by predators right okay so
other examples are in ants they use the
emit a pheromone as they're going on
area right to the end ganas idea of
swarm theory so with your robots with
your food your food delivery have you
thought about investigating this area at
all for kind of swarms once you start
realizing that you're going to be doing
a lot of these robots at scale you might
have you can use them for catering
situation for instance right you could
take twenty or thirty of these robots
all delivering food to the same location
in this big army of robots right right
to somebody's door is this something
that sounds interesting to you or
something that you've given any thought
to yet yes I don't think I haven't made
a thought like in there in the in the
business side but in the found site a
lot and so for example right now like a
lot of a lot of customers ask remember
this customer that asked me if she can't
she can rent the robot for their sister
birthday like middle sister birthday
party so those kind of things of course
like like robots like argh
like that that kind of things are going
to happen and there is an important
thing that we are working on and it's to
actually communicate rabbits yes so in
order to achieve that kind of things you
need to have like sign them and to find
ways to communicate one rabbit to an
hour so for us in the logistic part is
fundamental like we need to know where
is the rabbit and if we have a rabbit
close to another so for example we are
using - for example we have three scents
like almost three heat PS sensors in the
robot but in order ear also using
Bluetooth in each robot to recognize so
for example a drive will last connection
for any reason with one robot we can
recognize a rabbit that it's close it
just buy another rabbit that is passing
really close to that so those kind of
things of course we are too early in
that part they are going to cheat like
to help us to to achieve that kind of
solutions great so let's go and take
some questions from our students and the
community that will be great yeah so I'm
hoping that people out there have some
really good questions make sure you can
post your questions on questions for
Kiwi in our slack community or on our
YouTube live comment section right now
so this first question is for 9 a.m.
Kobe or I know this is a technical class
but I'm interested in the reasoning
behind Kiwis choice of target market
why choose college campuses specifically
as a target for food delivery fleets of
bots and I think that students are
awesome and I if you are going to build
a company it's really important that you
build it and like that you really like
your customers yes because you're going
to solve their problems and well college
campuses are and you have early adopters
and you have less variables to control
and the people are super fully you can
find talent so right now half of our
team is from UC Berkeley that it's our
first campus so it's like if I like our
mission is to
you to be in more campuses and it's
easier for us so I totally advise that
it's a very good market so if you want
to - I don't have to test a solution or
not even if it's robotics it doesn't
matter but it's very it's a very good
market to start perfect so next question
is from Pradeep Krishna okay hey how do
you make a low-cost robot what
approaches do you take to reduce the
cost so I think that the when you're
working with robotics and with engineers
they're like like you feel very tempted
to use expensive parts yes
so yeah let's say let's use the MA like
the expensive a stereo camera for 3d
mapping and let's use the most
sophisticated GPS
let's use the board that have the most
complete the more computer power but we
finally choose that like we are using a
aware of as you said yet some tx2 that
it's very it's a great board yeah it's a
great board and but and I think it's
really important to try to be recursive
yes so I feel very and like grateful to
don't have a lot of funds in the earlier
like before because that pushed our team
to be resourceful in using cameras to
replace sensors so actually it's a very
good spot to don't have a lot of funds
when you're willing to robot because
you're going to try to do it with with
very low money and then you call
innovate a little bit so yeah great
thank you so the next question is from
Igor he wants to know if you're hiring
and right now
we are we are always open to having new
people in the team so yeah feel free to
contact me if you're in this lack and in
this lack group and dislike just like
really sure that community yeah feel
free to contact me
yeah yeah so if you're not liking me
make sure you sign up for that
communities you can be people like
Felipe yes so the next question here is
from lemon Leno
Tavares Cabral excuse me sorry Lana if I
want to make robotics and
knowledge in passive and reactive
circuits so this might not be a question
yeah like like it depends on which robot
do you want to build sure yes so yeah
yeah it depends on which robot shares
yeah makes sense so next one is from
Tish person do robots need internet
connection or can they function without
it on which network does it rely to
communicate with other devices okay so
that's a very good question so a lot of
the computer vision and it's safer to do
it on site so right now like what for
example the computer vision and if you
are using and just one part that the
computer vision that it's and for
example much in learning and neural
networks and the first step is to and
make sure that you that it works yes but
then you actually can optimize the
noodle Network a lot so that the size is
and lower and also it's lighter and to
put it in a in a computer we have made
some tests and to that we run some much
learning process in just a raspberry pi
and that will be like a small computer
like sure computer power and we have
also test it test that with a with cloud
computer computer processing that is not
like you have like like it's maybe a
little bit more risky but it's something
that like we have to stream we have to
make sure that's why I said before that
you need to one part of the robotics is
to make sure that you have a strong
network software so yes so you can do it
and we are using and t-mobile but it
depends in when you're going to deploy
your robots because we have to test it
with all the couriers we have to be
tested with all the devices their hot
spot so it's it's a very interesting
benchmark and it depends a lot in when
are you going to deploy your robot so
yeah it's great great answer thank you
so the next one is still from the teach
I've heard that robots will replace
about one third of the actual human
labor force in the future do you think
that's true and we'll only pro
rumors and robot maintenance resist to
that trend yeah I think that it's too
early to talk about that but I think
it's true yes and so one of the things
like like for example and other people
ask me like okay you're you are
replacing normal couriers with your
robot and my first answer is that
students before like students can't
afford to have food deliberate to have
like to have a service and you have food
delivered so the first thing is that and
we are actually making sure that a lot
of people can live and with like with
less money so that's one part and there
are interesting experiments that a lot
of people are doing in that part because
for example self-driving the
self-driving technology is going to
replace like like I think that 20% of
the jobs have are you both with driving
a car yes
so that and that's something that is
going to happen it's unavoidable
so there are techniques experiments like
a universal basic income that have
showed that I think that that could be
very interesting and I think one of our
and one of my friends are working with a
human augmentation so I think there is a
very powerful in a solution to actually
connect robots and software and
computers with human brains so that
could open and new possibilities but the
most important thing is to is to still
too early to talk about that but we
can't stop the robot and the machine
learning and all the computation
revolution because it's going to be it's
going to allow to have a good life like
it's going to have less poverty a lot of
things yes yeah so the next question is
from Pradeep he wants to know what kind
of wheels you use in your delivery robot
so in the first one and we basically
hacked an RC car
the first version so I basically like
there is a big community of RC
enthusiast in the US so I remember that
I went to a rice of just RC cars
and I survived all the people like which
rabbit it's like like according to our
the characteristics and week and the
decision that we made is that we used an
Everest rabbit but it's a normal RC car
and basically we hacked that robot in
the new version we are testing with
different chassés one of the choices
that we are testing it's called nomad
and it's a 4wd that we can go to any
direction and can turn in our or WD
meaning four-wheel drive yeah
four-wheel drives and bad yes so it
there are a lot of a lot of solutions
out there in terms of chassés and yeah
cool great thanks next one is from Ricky
he wants to know what programming
languages you use so in in our like for
example in the in the oil noodle in the
old network part we are using Java yes
and we are also using C in our in the
right now we are testing with some parts
so I'm not sure like if we are going to
use a B FX meaning or if we are going to
use a big hook or what kind of of
connector we are going to use but it
depends also in the language and you are
use the programming language for the
image recognition part we are using
Python and mostly Python and in the
noodle network part where you think
we're using care a framework that it's
called Chara's and yeah so it's a lot of
our deep learning students you know you
with carrot so so like like you like it
depends because it's a really complex
problem so you need a lot of languages
yeah great so next question is from
Alvaro do you use your robot track
pedestrian position in velocity I wonder
if you can adjust the robot's velocity
in trajectory based on this data to
speed up the deliveries yes that's one
of the challenges and the thing is that
there are some blind spots so I don't
know we are in in telegraphing one of
the main street you can actually speed
up the robot but there is someone that
could be like
could be and that going out from a
restaurant and it's really difficult
like even a human can do it so I think
that what we can do is that in open
spaces we can do it in places that we
have buildings in one side it's really
risky so and but of course we are
measuring a pedestrian so that's
something that it's not really complex
and we like if we are in an openness
place and we don't have pedestrians
around us we can speed up the robot but
most of them in most of the locations
it's really like you have to go at the
same speed of a human walking yeah okay
next question is from Jamie yeah so I'm
from Latin America okay and robotics is
my dream can you give me some advice
yeah yeah like the first advice is to
start so there are a lot of actually
recommend that the first robot that I
started like there the company is called
plumb geek and I started with a robot
called gringo and it has all the sensors
it has like like you can Castlerock
sensors it's affordable it costs like
$70 and you can and run your first
Arduino programs and it's very very good
so the first one is that if you can
afford a cheap robot to start playing
around it's good one and also if you can
take like like classes online and learn
more about that it's also good and if
you actually want to learn more join a
startup during our robotic a startup yes
it's a great idea so this next question
is from sha hula doula what kind of AI
have you built into your robots so it
sounds like you have a ton of it with
the convolutional neural nets it's
probably some deep learning in there you
know outside of that yeah so yeah it's
really difficult to like what is to
define AI but uhm yeah since for example
we are using like beside the ones that
you just mentioned we are using computer
vision to recognize so there are some
times that we need to do sensor fusion
so we're the ones that doesn't know what
is sensor fusion is to actually a mix
all if you have unreliable data from
different sources you
and mix those data and use very fun math
and statistics to have a more reliable
model yes so one of the things that we
are using as a sensor is to recognize
patterns in buildings to navigate it's
still too early but we have made some
very good progress and it's for example
a with like a human like before GPS like
human when you're worth walking in a
sidewalk you're recognizing which corner
just because you recognized that there
was a bank in the corner or there was a
restaurant or there was I don't know a
posture so we are using two computer
vision to recognize those kind of things
and teach our robots to like where you
are without internet connection or
without the need to communicate with us
tell it satellite so those kind of
things are things that we are doing and
also like all the computer vision part
like with the noodle net and 3d
environments AI so we have in the in the
model that we are building we have a
people cars a weather condition that we
are using like artificial intelligence
perfect so the last question from our
audience okay this is from SRAM he wants
to know what the state of robotics will
be ten years from now yeah what do you
envision ten years in a long time yeah I
think I can I can I can talk very
confident about my space so in ten years
all the last mile deliveries are going
to be made by robots that's going to
happen it's unavoidable and it's very
likely that and not just in college
campuses in in offices and not just with
food also with important documents with
small packages or also with big packages
and what we want to do is to is to have
a Kiwi but in all those deliveries yeah
perfect
let's go for ten years on them yes so
that's it for today's Q&A if you like to
learn more about robotics visit
udacity.com/google being sued acid
e-comm Felipe thank you very much thank
you very much benefit ah thanks a lot
thanks for coming in yeah until next
time
you